Jake:你会吗
Jake: Do you know how?
Tasha: 我也会一点
Tasha: I know a little bit.
Tasha: 为什么会
Tasha: Why do you ask?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why is that?
Tasha: 嗯我本来以前暑假的时候
Tasha: Well, back during summer vacation...
Tasha: 就是找份班上
Tasha: I was looking for a job.
Tasha: 然后我妈就给我介绍了一个亲戚
Tasha: My mom introduced me to a relative.
Tasha: 那个亲戚开乐器班的哦
Tasha: That relative ran a music class.
Tasha: 他他让我是帮他就是卖课
Tasha: He had me help him sell lessons.
Tasha: 就是路边有小孩就喊他过来学乐器
Tasha: I'd call kids over from the street to learn music.
Tasha: 一天给我100块
Tasha: He'd pay me 100 yuan a day.
Tasha: 结果我干了10天
Tasha: I did it for 10 days.
Tasha: 我都没有卖出去这一单
Tasha: I didn't sell a single lesson.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why's that?
Tasha: 然后他就让我自己报名学
Tasha: Then he had me sign up for lessons myself.
Tasha: 这算我唯一的一单
Tasha: That was my only sale.
Jake:好吧我没找到
Jake: Okay, I couldn't find it.
Tasha: 我给他干了一个月
Tasha: I worked for him for a month.
Jake:这个是吗
Jake: Is this it?
Lucia: 这个是吗
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 给他干了一个月就卖出了我自己这一单
Tasha: Worked for him for a month and only sold my own lesson.
Lucia: 那个厚那个
Lucia: That thick one?
Jake:然后就会吉他了
Jake: And now you can play guitar?
Tasha: 没有会
Tasha: Not really.
Tasha: 会弹了一首歌
Tasha: I can play one song.
Jake:白色的吗
Jake: The white one?
Jake:什么白白色的
Jake: What white, what white one?
Jake:谢斌竹我们
Jake: Xie Bin Zhu, we...
Jake:哎我们
Jake: Hey, we...
Jake:不用了不用了
Jake: No, no, it's fine.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:这个还帮你修一下吧
Jake: I'll help you fix this.
Tasha: 你打算用啥给人修
Tasha: What are you going to use to fix it?
Jake:浇水喽
Jake: Just some water.
Jake:他的手环
Jake: His bracelet...
Shure:  手环断了
Shure: The bracelet broke.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人: 这是好的还是不好的
Others: Is this a good one or a bad one?
Lucia: 挺好的别修了
Lucia: It's pretty good, don't fix it.
Lucia: 你觉得修得好吗
Lucia: Do you think it’s fixed well?
Lucia: 你知道为什么会坏吗
Lucia: Do you know why it broke?
Lucia: 他弄坏了
Lucia: He broke it.
其他人: 怎么坏了
Others: How did it break?
Lucia: 他砸了我的手
Lucia: He smashed my hand.
其他人: 等一下啊
Others: Wait a second.
其他人:我很我我很
Others: I really I really
其他人: 我很懂翡翠的哦
Others: I really understand jade.
Tasha: 这不是翡翠
Tasha: This isn’t jade.
其他人:这是一个糯种
Others: This is a type of "glutinous" jade.
Shure:  这是一个玉嘛
Shure: This is a type of jade, right?
其他人: 玉和翡翠不一样
Others: Jade and this are different.
其他人: 这是一个糯种的啊
Others: This is a type of "glutinous" jade.
其他人: 这是一个种水很一般
Others: The quality is quite average.
Jake:就会俩词
Jake: You only know two phrases.
Jake:哈哈哈就会俩词
Jake: Haha, you only know two phrases.
Jake:币怎么样了
Jake: How’s the coin?
其他人: 币还没有币
Others: The coin isn’t there yet.
其他人:no币no code no code no币no
Others: No coin, no code, no code, no coin.
Jake: no币no environment
Jake: No coin, no environment.
Tasha: 都中是什么意思
Tasha: What does "all types" mean?
Jake:no空挡
Jake: No gap.
其他人: 豆种豆种啊
Others: Bean type, bean type.
Shure:  豆种糯种冰种水种
Shure: Bean type, glutinous type, icy type, watery type.
Lucia: 哦哦你家是做这个的吗
Lucia: Oh, is this what your family does?
其他人: 没有天天刷小视频
Others: No, I just watch videos every day.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 给你女朋友买是吗
Tasha: Are you buying it for your girlfriend?
Jake:学专家了是吧
Jake: You’ve become an expert, huh?
Jake:就学成专家了
Jake: You’ve become an expert.
Jake:自学成才自学成才
Jake: Self-taught, self-taught.
其他人: 我买不起这些东西
Others: I can’t afford this stuff.
Jake:哦这么牛逼
Jake: Oh, so impressive.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?